wow
um you first of all you're welcome you
thanked us you said you wouldn't be here
without ETA you did I heard that tonight
didn't you clearly we've meant a lot to
you when you uh originated your brand
you came on the ET set in 1981 and you
were there with your little mics with
the ET on it and I immediately wanted to
call my lawyers to sue you
even though my film at the time was
called a boy's life secretly it was E.T
and I thought oh my God they took my
title and look all these years later
we've managed to co-exist yes we've
mended fences and now we're all here
together yes you say you've been wanting
to make this movie since you were 17.
what took so long then you're Steven
Spielberg wasn't so much wanting to make
the movie uh from 17. 17 is when all
this happened to me that's when my
parents separated and got divorced it's
just that I've been sitting on these
stories and you know it's hard process a
divorce it's hard to process the
uniqueness of what created this
separation and divorce in my family
that's one of the most unique things
about my family is how this all came to
be with my father's best friend and my
mother also her best friend and so I had
to process this and it didn't it didn't
come out as a script called the
fablements it came out in a lot of other
movies I've made it came out in the
scene where Richard Dreyfuss is mad at
his dad in Close Encounters and starts
slamming the door calling him cry baby
it came out in drips and drabs
throughout a lot of my movies until this
gentleman right here Tony Kushner
started to help me organize these ideas
into something that could be told
someday as a film is it true that your
lovely wife Kate said you gotta do this
Stephen yeah no she said she got to do
this on my mom when she was alive I had
always talked to her about someday
telling the story and she would always
say at the restaurant you know she'd say
Steve she'd reach over take my hands and
hers she'd leaned forward like it was a
secret what are you gonna tell our story
so that was on my mom's mind more than
my dad's also Keith shouted you out
tonight and he said he would love to do
a short round spin-off would you think
about that yeah well you know in a way
well Short Round I think we've retired
his number and we retired this number
and I think it was
1983 because he just knocked it out of
the park of that movie he was incredible
I was so impressed by key I cast him
with dick Donner in The Goonies do you
remember he played data in The Goonies
and I'm so proud of keys win tonight one
of the things he said though too was
that you were one of the first to put an
Asian character in a really big budget
film in mainstream movies and that's
something that he really appreciated
because he felt seen
by you that was how we designed the
script you know Gloria katzen Willard
hike wrote the script and George Lucas
wrote the story and he was always going
to be an Asian kid he didn't even come
in to read for the part his cousin was
reading for the part and we saw Keith
sitting in the waiting room and said can
we bring this younger kid in to meet me
and that's sort of how it happened
Michelle's over here like are you
kidding me all of these stories hearing
this now
Amazing by the way you two were
brilliant as Steven's parents what was
it like every day turning out to him
saying did I get it right is this what
you what you imagine this is what you
saw
I I you know but but by that point
honestly we have to just be ourselves
and we have to be Burton Mitzi I think
if we were looking to Steven Spielberg
as we think of him tonight we would have
been dead in the water frankly so I
think he was just our collaborator and
our friends from the very first Zoom he
met us with an open heart and uh intense
vulnerability and emotional intelligence
in his eyes about his family and his
parents and we just tried to give that
back to him Stephen James Cameron told
me earlier tonight that you told him you
would meet him at the party but you'd be
drinking ginger ale now Gabriel said he
would like for you to do a tequila shot
come on he told me so can that happen
tonight you know something if I did a
tequila shot right now it would take
about 30 seconds for it to kick in and
it would take another seven minutes for
the ambulance to get here
so the killer shot is definitely out
Gabriel sorry I tried buddy
a little white wine maybe once a week a
Guinness I like I like Guinness okay but
that's about it that's about it I can
understand that yeah yeah but it
wouldn't happen to me now no I wouldn't
fall down
maybe that's who you need to drink with
that's you need to drink you guys have
an amazing night tonight take care
Everybody Take Care congratulations
foreign